[Music]
welcome to the climate show with me tom
heap today it is all about making stuff
and powering stuff without cooking the
planet we are in hull on the humber
estuary we're here because this city and
this region are beginning to turn the
tide on climate change if they succeed
it shows some of the most polluting
industries can be cleaned up if they
don't well you get the picture
offshore in the north sea some of the
world's largest wind farms are taking
shape and many of them are made here but
so much of the big business on homicide
is dirty business in climate terms at
least
power stations chemical plants
refineries and steel mills like it or
not still pillars of our economy a full
40 percent of the uk's emissions from
industry come from this patch and
greening them will be the hard yards of
decarbonization so can it be done well
later on we'll hear from a local
environmental champion alongside a
renewable energy entrepreneur and i'll
be putting it all in context with the
help of our own science guru tom clark
but first i take a look along the banks
of what could be a river of redemption
for hundreds of years the people of the
humber estuary have driven economic
opportunity in fishing
whaling and then as a coal-fired
powerhouse
if green tech and renewable energy is
really going to revolutionize our dirty
industries it's got to happen at scale
and these turbine blades give you a clue
that that's happening
they've made close to 2000 of them here
this one is 81 meters long but by the
end of the year they'll be producing
them at 108 meters
this is the siemens gamesa plant right
next to hull city centre they used to
export coal from this dock but now they
ship turbine blades across the world and
closer to home
these blades will be uh in the uk
actually in scotland and the single turn
of the turbine will power a house for
around 24 hours they opened in 2016 and
employ around a thousand people 200 more
posts will be created within a year it's
so amazing that people can go home they
can say what they've been doing at work
and that they're actually making a
difference you know clean energy for
generations to come these things feel
fairly futuristic but any further
innovations yeah i mean already this
year we've made the first recyclable
blades that are out now
in wind turbine farm in germany which is
really exciting we're already as a
company looking at hydrogen production
through wind turbines as well
as the uk government has promised to
quadruple offshore electrical power
generation by 2030 growth looks assured
but as the wind doesn't always blow it
can't do the whole decarbonizing job
this is probably over
10 times bigger than this wind farm that
you can see in front of us
this new gas-fired power station up
river will be the most efficient in
europe and it's a step in cleaning up
old industries like chemicals refineries
and ports the long-term idea of the
humber industrial cluster plan is to
capture and bury carbon dioxide before
switching to hydrogen as a fuel but it's
a way off
we've been talking about carbon capture
and storage for at least two decades now
we've got a brand new power station and
it hasn't got it fitted why not
well because there wasn't the
infrastructure
the policy the frameworks in order to be
able to actually build a carbon capture
and storage plant there's no pipe work
there's no transport there's no
depleted gas field
to be able to do that right now so do
you honestly believe that the fossil
fuel effort is changing its spots and
can become climate friendly absolutely
otherwise i wouldn't be in this job you
know when i look at my children when i
look at my seven-year-old and my
three-year-old i want to tell them i was
part of that change but the fact is you
need flexible power you need to be able
to switch the lights on when the wind
isn't blowing when the sun isn't shining
but when it is shining the smart people
of hull are making more of it so sun
solar panel but what's new here well
solar panels normally just convert
sunlight into electricity but what's
truly novel here is we're capturing what
would normally be wasted heat energy and
recirculating it back into what could be
a domestic heating system so i've never
thought that and i've got panels on my
own roof that are making a lot of
wattage but there's heat there as well
is there absolutely yes and normal panel
will only convert about 20 percent of
that solar energy into useful
electricity what we're doing here is
capturing that
typically waste to 80 of energy and
converting it into something useful
this panel which produces both
electricity and heating is just one idea
from aura the low carbon innovation hub
spun out of hull university which
provides a workshop space to fill the
gap between ideas and industry here they
are strength testing bio plastics
they've even developed a low carbon air
conditioning system used for cooling
computer servers which has slashed 53
000 pounds off the council's energy
bills it uses evaporation similar to
human sweating
and for the man who has everything
they're also working on this
an open electric tank possibly more
useful for low-carbon farming as
industries decarbonize and inventions
appear hull could be on track for the
future
so a low-carbon transition happening in
business but what about home life is the
message crossing the threshold well to
talk about this i'm joined by jordan
brompton from green tech firm my energy
and martin budd he's in charge of the
climate change brief at hull city
council well 75
of the 166 wards in this city are ranked
among the most deprived in england so
martin people don't have a lot of cash
to spend on this change are they engaged
they are yes and you're quite right you
know it's a real challenge within the
city in terms of the level of
deprivation but at the same time people
are very you know very proud of the city
very proud of the changes that are
happening within the city and obviously
the siemens camisa planted some really
big show of actually how decarbonization
can make a big difference and what have
you been able to do in the council in
terms of actual actually people's homes
we've been able to do quite a lot
actually we've done a lot of work in
terms of our own houses so we own 26 000
homes within the city so we've done all
the cavity wall insulation within then
the roof but also we did an external
installation putting that in station on
the outside of people's homes installing
pvs those photovoltaic panels and some
of the homes as well and also it's about
actually making sure the homes are as
energy efficient as possible so it's a
real challenge in terms of what we've
got to do jordan tell me a little bit
about my energy what is it you do and
how does it kind of fit into this
overall picture yeah so we're a tech
business we design and manufacture
ecosmart products that go in the home
predominantly homes with solar panels or
an electric vehicle and um our whole
mission is to decarbonize heating and
transport and it's our sort of system
that
give me an example of how those would
work what would that tech do for
instance so if you've got solar panels
or you can divert your surplus power to
a hot water tank giving you essentially
a free hot tank of water or if you've
got an electric vehicle you can use a
solar running roof to divert your car
battery if you don't have solar you can
use cheap green energy tariffs and
what's the recent uh what was the recent
change been like for your company uh
it's been dramatic
we've experienced rapid growth which
shows that
how rapid rapid very rapid so we've gone
from you know in 2017 shipping 20 to 30
products that we manufacture ourselves
to this this year three thousand a week
three thousand a week and what about
employees we've got four like just
coming up to 400 employees now in the uk
and we're expanding all over the globe
as well and how does it feel to be kind
of part of this chat
wild
so we saw a problem um that needed
fixing and we set about doing it we
didn't anticipate this level of growth
but it's fantastic six i've worked in
the renewable industry for a long time
and i've seen its peaks and troughs but
it seems like the demand is there now
the mainstream consciousness is there
and people want renewable energy in
their homes they want to take control of
their own power yeah i know you're
getting the help that you need from the
from the council and the like you know
you make some demands you know what we
do we get a lot of support from the
local government and we get a lot of
support from yeah from from at the
minute it's there's never been a better
time to get solar it's not percent that
at the moment on solar and battery
storage and because of the cost of
energy um having solar can reduce your
bills quite dramatically
is there a bit of a symbiosis here
between the kind of authorities and and
the businesses
there is yes i mean it's important you
know we only are going to decarbonize is
by growing the businesses that are
involved in this area in the tech area
so it's important for us as an authority
to work with the college colleges and
the providers in our own training
training bodies to actually make sure
that the courses are there
for people that actually they can get
trained and they can then actually go
into the businesses because it's
small businesses make a vast majority of
these of the economy of the city how
difficult is it to find the right people
it's difficult um we're managing um but
we do we have got a skills gap not just
locally but in the whole country um you
know to decarbonize that many homes and
to decarbonize the country like we do
we're going to need a lot of upskilling
um you were telling me earlier about an
electrician who's got what how many
people are his books i know one
electrician who's got 400 on his waiting
list for solar panels just in yorkshire
wow that's an extraordinary isn't it
we saw in the film i made that was
largely about uh bigger businesses and
and but do you think there's a role for
the kind of the smaller business and and
the and in the household absolutely
there's a huge role for small businesses
um to decarbonize heat and transport
we're going to need a mix of all sorts
and we're going to need small businesses
cropping up to support it's like
supporting the supply chain of the
larger businesses and
millions of homes out there that need
that need renewable energy we need
electricians we need electronics
firmware firmware writers software
writers
um we need a whole host of industries
that support it and do you think the
sort of if you like the the average
person for another word is on this
journey yet um are they beginning to
engage with this because in a sense
we've we've done some of the easy stuff
we've you know got big turbines we've
got nuclear power stations you know
they're relatively low carbon you can
flick your switch and forget but martin
do you think you know people need to
think about this a little bit more it's
time to engage i think it is yeah and i
think you know we are engaging with the
residents of the city and they're
engaging with us around this and it's a
whole variety i think that's it the
whole decarbonisation piece is really
touching people's homes and stuff so
that energy efficiency is a really
important message at the moment and
stuff but it always has been but also
that change in transportation as well as
people start to see charge points in the
city you know and those are able to you
know have electric vehicles but some of
the businesses in the city are changing
they're putting electric fleets in so
the experience of driving electric
vehicle and what that means so it's
about actually getting people familiar
and understanding what these
technologies and briefly are you able to
sort of help them with that in terms of
i don't know planning decisions or
highways and things we are yes so we put
the charge points like in our own in our
own car parks and stuff that we have
within the city but also we're running
in projects with the universe with the
university of hull around air source
heat pumps we've got one large
manufacturer in the city that's set up
his own training body yeah for you know
so it's it it's happening training is
absolutely key as you mentioned earlier
but what about government policy uh
overall what is it what is it you want
to see and perhaps haven't seen quite
enough of in recent years i think the
key word is consistency like
you know we just need to see some
consistency we don't want anything pull
in from us right now i mean if it could
stay at zero percent back for getting
solar on batteries or then bonus because
then people have got the confidence to
invest in the smaller businesses to take
on those extra staff to upskill to train
but if it's very choppy it's difficult
to make those solid decisions
and
just explain why when it's choppy as you
call it it can be so damaging for a
business briefly yeah because what i was
around when we had the feeding tariff
when it was at its peak and people were
getting solar and stop solar installed
because they were getting paid by the
government to have that but then so
electricians were popping up all over
the place fitting lots and lots of
panels economy was booming everybody was
happy but then all of a sudden the
government slashed the tariffs and when
they make drastic decisions like that
businesses go out of business but it was
a very generous subsidy and i couldn't
go on forever could it i agree it's a
heavily subsidized industry it's not a
buoyant industry um but there's a
balance it's just got to be incremental
and it's got to be consistent and very
brilliant what about that
messaging from government as well as
policy how important is that we keep
that consistent that climate change
matters it does i mean it's incredibly
important we get that consistency of
message that that shows you know netsir
is where we're going and everything is
supportive of that in terms of
government messages in terms of policy
because that gives people confidence it
gives individuals confidence his
business confidence and gives investors
confidence and that's what we need to
actually make the change
martin jordan thank you very much indeed
and not a bad day to be waterside here
in halls
well you can scan the qr code on your
screen and listen to a special episode
of the sky news daily podcast with chloe
kalpan and our own climate change and
energy correspondent hannah thomas peter
they'll be discussing what liz truss and
rishi sunak have promised or not to
tackle the climate crisis you can
subscribe to the daily for free wherever
you get your podcasts
coming up after the break
tom clark has been looking at whether we
have the right grid the right wires in
place to connect green tech and get it
doing its decarbonizing job and we'll
raise our eyes beyond the horizon to see
how hull fits in to the national picture
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show before
the break we were looking at
climate-friendly breakthroughs and
challenges facing this most industrial
of estuaries the humber
and i found an excuse to drive a
mobility scooter crossed with a tank
but how does what's happening here
relate to our net zero by 2050 goal and
what might be holding back the low
carbon tide it's time for another
session of the tomtom club today with
our science editor tom clark tom welcome
very nice to see you in person hi again
tom
good thanks uh right um we discussed
earlier on the fact that there's a lot
of aspiration to clean up these dirty
industries but some of the big
infrastructure hydrogen in
carbon out big pipes just not there yet
they are the biggest challenges and the
ones i think we've got the least answers
on you know moving carbon dioxide around
is something that sounds simple the
technology we sort of
know what to do but no one's actually
ever really done it
anything like the scale we'd need to to
make an industrial cluster work like
this once you've moved the carbon
dioxide around where do you put it now
we know it can stay in offshore oil and
gas fields but what kind of oil offshore
gas fields how close are they how
expensive is it going to be together and
how long it will stay there for once you
put it down in the ground it's a lot of
work to to do a lot of problems to solve
and we haven't really started tackling
them yet and there is a sort of there is
a bit of government policy here isn't i
think it's a billion pounds over quite a
few years but there's been a bit of stop
start here it certainly has i mean
you know and
yeah there was a billion pounds
available to solve the ccs problem the
carbon capture and storage problem
about a decade ago that became available
and then just before companies have been
into it uh time of national crisis the
the rug was pulled the money went away
and that said everyone back quite a long
time we've now the treasury is
recommitted you know there is a billion
pound pot to see ccs at scale within the
2030s but given our targets that's quite
a long way off and there's still a lot
of problems to solve
but does it make sense to be bringing
these things together in these so-called
clusters absolutely and it's not by
accident they are not happening
organically
these there was a plan in place to try
and bring these clusters together
there's some opportunities there
basically if you've got heavy industry
there already which we have in this area
you've got lots of renewable electricity
coming in from offshore north sea and
this lovely breeze you've also got
places you could put uh gas into into
the north sea for example there are
companies that could share resources in
terms of storing that they could share
pipe network if you've got hydrogen in
the mix as well you could have a hub for
generating that and then users sharing
it it all makes sense they're responding
in place for these clusters but lots of
little challenges to solve along the way
and i'm guessing some of the planning
decisions are easier here in these more
industrial landscapes than they might be
in the cute areas of the south east
but how do we connect what's happening
here to the rest of the country so yeah
i mean
centralizing stuff in a cluster is all
well and good that's very important it's
going to be these are going to be the
laboratories where we solve lots of
these problems that ultimately might be
extended more broadly across the uk but
there's a bigger challenge
how do you get all this new renewable
electricity around britain with a
national grid infrastructure that was
designed around large fossil fuel power
plants humming away constantly day and
night when the wind doesn't blow and the
sun doesn't shine that raises big
problems for the grid and they're
getting bigger as we put more renewables
onto the grid also the challenge is
looming because we're consuming more
electricity think about our electric
cars and our air source heat pumps that
we're switching away from boilers that
presents challenges in our report for
your program we went and looked at
exactly how people are starting to think
about addressing that issue
we won't get far towards a zero carbon
energy future without a lot more of
these
huge banks of batteries connected
directly to the electricity grid
so if there's
instability in the grid or the shocks to
the system that's really where batteries
comes in and intermittent renewable
energy
is a critical part of our net zero
future yeah um but it has to be
stabilized and batteries are one of the
best ways or probably the best way at
the moment
this battery at cowley substation near
oxford is huge it can store and release
50 megawatts of electricity enough for
thousands of homes
it's pioneering too combining fast and
powerful lithium batteries with a new
type of liquid battery called a vanadium
flow cell
not quite as much umph as lithium but it
can be charged and recharged almost
infinitely without a loss of performance
it's a lower power density but it really
complements the lithium-ion battery
enabling us to not only trade power
but also manage frequency
in a much more efficient way and also
limits the wear and tear on the
lithium-ion battery
massive batteries like this are going to
be increasingly important as we put more
and more renewables onto our electricity
grid to fill in the gaps on the days
when the sun isn't shining and the wind
isn't blowing
but storage of power is also going to
become more important as our demand for
electricity rises
take electric vehicles this is europe's
most powerful electric car charging hub
connected directly to the oxford battery
just as well three cars plugged into
these superchargers at the same time
draw more power than 100 homes
if you add the demands of electrically
powered air source heat pumps into the
mix you can start to see why electricity
demand is projected to double by 2050
are we going to be more storage like
this so we're going to need a lot more
grid because um the places where we need
electricity and the big cities and the
big industrial centers are not
normally near where the new supplies of
electricity will be which is where it
tends to be really windy offshore off
the coast of scotland and while the
government has been pretty clear in
setting out its plans for low carbon
electricity generation from things like
more wind farms how it's going to
redesign the grid with all the backup
power and storage we're going to need is
less clear
we've got no time to waste but the
government has uh recently put out a
consultation on what that future
electricity market arrangements might
work
and that is a much needed step what's
really important for the new government
coming in is they do not lose any
momentum because the grid we got it at
the moment is creaking a bit it's under
pressure and therefore getting these
reforms in place is absolutely uh and
getting on with it is a really urgent
pressing issue for the new government
fascinating point that about
re-engineering the grid i mean i hear it
a lot as i go around the countryside of
people with all sorts of renewable
energy projects that they just can't get
on because the wires aren't there that
is a big challenge you know we've got
the trunk cables the national grid which
is the kind of the the backbone of the
network but all the peripheral nerves
the ones that go into people's homes
they some of them are very very old some
of them are being put in underpowered
there's a big challenge for those
smaller network operators so how they're
going to plug more energy
hungry homes into the grid and challenge
how everyone's going to pay for it yeah
and do we think the government kind of
gets this as a potential area for
government funding or are they relying
on the market to do it now some players
in this thing said the market can do
this alone so um edf renewables who we
were speaking to with that that big
battery for example that runs completely
without subsidy they can exploit
ups and downs in the grid to make plenty
of money to to to roll out many many
more of those across the country and
they have ambitions to do that but other
parts of this are not going to pay for
themselves and they will need investment
now is that going to be direct
investment i very much doubt it because
that's not been the political direction
of travel for a long time so what is the
market-based mechanism to do it one
thing the government has been urged to
do for a long time is reform the way we
buy and sell electricity
right now it's all pegged to the price
of natural gas there's anyone paying
electricity bill at the moment knows
that is a ridiculous thing it seems to
me that the grid is in some ways the
sort of
unseen
nervous system of the country it ought
to be kind of more known it ought to be
kind of our our map because it does
really matter but i wonder if
politicians sort of struggle to put
money to it they'd rather put you know
new train lines or other new glamorous
things and it is complicated and it's
also changing quite quickly so we looked
at battery storage but we're going to
need ways of storing power for much
longer periods of time possibly even
seasonally you know as we have different
high pressure like we had this summer
it's not very much wind around but
you've got a bit of solar how do you
design a grid that's going to be truly
flexible what are your long-term power
storage technologies how do you design a
grid around that when you don't really
know what that is going to be doing in
20 years time and we've had a lot of
whole favoritism here just briefly where
else in the country is looking to
similar changes there are other clusters
too you know in t-side there's there's
there's work going on there the north
west of england also in scotland these
hubs for innovation for trying these
technologies and also drawing the brains
that we need to try and solve the
problems tom clark thanks very much
indeed well that's all for this week and
the last in this run of programs but
we'll be back and we want your help
if you scan the qr code here you can go
to our website and ask any questions
about climate change and are there any
stories we should be covering you'll
have noticed we're particularly
interested in solutions to climate
change what shall we be talking about
and answering when we come back but
that's it for now goodbye from homicide
[Music]
you